GAME.
IT'S STUPID.
HOPE YOU HAD A PLEASANT WEEKEND.
I KNOW I DID, AND EVEN BETTER,
THERE WERE NO WITNESSES.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN SOMEONE ADMITS
TO WRONGDOING YEARS AFTER THE
WRONGDOING HAS BEEN COMMITTED?
FOR ME, IT WAS GETTING THE
MENUDO TATTOO REMOVED, BUT I
WONDER, DOES A CONFESSION HAPPEN
BECAUSE THE GUILT BECAME TOO
MUCH OR DID THEY REALIZE THEIR
CONFESSION CARRIES NO REAL
CONSEQUENCE?
THEY GET TO HAVE THEIR CAKE AND
EAT IT, TOO, OR IN BRIAN'S CASE,
TWO CAKES AND A BUCKET OF CORN
DOGS.
SO EASY.
SO CHEAP, BUT SO TRUE.
ALL RIGHT, SPEAK OF THE TSUNAMI
OF PEOPLE NOW ADMITTING MEDIA
COVERED UP UNDER BIDEN'S LAPTOP.
AFTER TWO YEARS AS JOE AS
PRESIDENT, PEOPLE ARE ADMITTING
WHAT WE KNEW ALL ALONG.
>> HUNTEDDER BIDEN, I'M SORRY.
YOU MADE A LIVING WHO WAS TAKING
MONEY JUST BECAUSE YOU WERE THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S SON.
YOU HAD INFLUENCE.
YOU HAD $4.8 MILLION FROM
CHINESE ENERGY COMPANIES.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE LEFT WING
MAYBE JUST BURIED THE STORY
BECAUSE IT WASN'T PART OF THEIR
NARRATIVE AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE
DON'T TRUST THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: IT LOOKS LIKE IT.
IT'S ALSO LIKE HE'S -- DARE I
SAY -- WOKE BUT THIS A GOOD WAY.
CREDIT HIM.
WHEN HE'S RIGHT.
HE'S RIGHT.
EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
OWNING UP CLAIMING THE HUNTER
STORY IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RECKONING.
THAT DOESN'T EVEN INCLUDE THE
MILLIONS HE SPENT ON HOOKERS OR
KUNG PAO CHICKEN.
IF HUNTER WORKED ANY HARDER FOR
THE CHINESE, HE'D SPEND HIS
WEEKENDS SEWING NIKES.
BUT WHILE "THE POST" ADMITS
BIDEN FAMILY PROMPTED BY TRADING
WITH HIS NAME OVERSEAS, IT'S
LIKE BIDEN DIDN'T ACT
INCORRUPTLY.
HIS SON SUDDENLY EARNING
MILLIONS IS SOMETHING HE
WOULDN'T NOTICE?
LIKE THE GROWING STAIN ON THE
FRONT OF HIS TROUSERS?
"THE POST" ASKED THE DUMBEST
QUESTION OF THE YEA.
WHY IS CONFIRMATION OF A STORY
THAT SURFACED IN THE FALL OF
2020 EMERGING ONLY NOW?
WELL, GEE WHIZ, POST, WHY DON'T
YOU ASK YOUR OWN NEWS BUREAU?
THE PRESS ASKING WHY THE STORY
IS ONLY EMERGING NOW.
IT'S LIKE O.J. SIMPSON JUST
ASKING WHAT HAPPENED TO HIS
EX-WIFE NICOLE OR SCOTT PETERSEN
PUTTING UP MISSING POSTERS OF
HIS WIFE ALL AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
YOUR HANDS WERE ALL OVER THIS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THEN NOTED
THAT AFTER THE "NEW YORK POST"
PUBLISHED THE BLOCKBUSTER PIECE,
"TWITTER BLOCKED A STORY
ALTOGETHER, SUSPENDED THE "NEW
YORK POST'S" ACCOUNT FOR SHARING
STORE THEFULLY THE ALGORITHMS
THAT GOVERNOR USERS' NEWS
FEEDS."
THANK YOU, WE KNEW.
THE CULPRITS WERE SIPPING LATTES
IN SILICON VALLEY.
NOW "THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" VOUCHED FOR
MANY OF THE E-MAILS AND CITED
THE PROMPTED ALLEGATIONS OF THE
COVER-UP OR IF THAT'S A DOUBLE
STANDARD IN THE TREATMENT OF
CONSERVATIVE AND LIBERAL
POLITICIAN BUSINESS MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AND SOCIAL MEDIA SITES.
WELL, HELLO THERE, SLEEPY HEADS.
DID YOU HAVE A NICE NAP?
OF COURSE, WHOPO OFFERS A LAME
DEFENSE SAYING WE'VE ALL BEEN
UNWITTING TOOLS OF RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE SO IT WAS ONLY TRUE TO
SUSPECT OF A SIMILAR PLOT HERE.
THE EDITORS WEREN'T UNWITTING,
THEY WERE JUST A BUNCH OF TOOLS.
I DON'T REMEMBER THEM BEING
PRUDENT ABOUT THE OTHER PHONY
PLOTS.
THEY WERE ONLY PRUDENT ABOUT ONE
REAL ONE AND THEY CONCLUDE WITH
THE SOLEMN IDIOCY.
THE LESSON LEARNED FROM 2016 WAS
TO HEIR ON THE SIDE OF SETTING
ASIDE QUESTIONABLE MATERIAL IN
THE HEAT OF THE POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN.
LESSON LEARNED FROM 2020 MAY
WELL BE THERE'S ALSO A DANGER OF
SUPPRESSING ACCURATE AND
RELEVANT STORIES.
DO YOU SEE WHAT THEY DID THERE?
IT WAS IMPORTANT TO BURY IT THEN
BUT IT'S NOT TO BURY IT NOW
WHICH MEANS IT'S TIME FOR
"GREG'S SUPER DULLLEX DOUBLE
WHAMMY CONSPIRACY HERE TO WITH
90% MORE CONSPIRACY AND MORE
TINFOIL."
THE MEDIA AMITS TO THE LAPTOP
NOW AND NOT THEM.
WHY?
THE DEMS GOT IN.
THEY WON.
LIKE PAYING A SMALL FINE FOR
BEHAVIOR THAT PAID YOU MILLIONS.
WITH BIDEN, THAT'S ONLY WORTH
THOUSANDS.
COULD TO BE THE MEDIA KNOWS
INDICTMENTS ARE COMING DOWN SO
WHY NOT SPEED IT UP AND GET IT
OVER WITH AWAY FROM 2024 WHILE
JOE IS STILL IN POWER SO IT'S
EASY FOR HIM TO PARDON HIS SON
AND MAYBE HIS BROTHER BEFORE JOE
IS WHEELED OFF ON A TWO-WHEEL
HAND TRUCK LIKE HANNIBAL LECTOR?
THEN THE DEEMS COULD REPLACE HIM
WITH A CANDIDATE WHO DOESN'T
NEED A CHEAT SHEET TO TELL YOU
HIS ADDRESS.
I WONDER WHAT JOE HAS TO SAY.
>> NO.
NO.
COME ON, MAN.
LOOK, THERE'S NO LYING ANYMORE.
IT'S JUST WE UPDATED YOU.
THAT'S ALL.
WE SAID THE STORY WASN'T TRUE.
NOW WE SAY IT'S TRUE.
WE UPDATED IT.
THAT'S ALL.
LIKE AN OLD PHONE OR COMPUTER,
YOU HAVE TO GIVE IT AN UPDATE OR
YOUR HOUSE U DO A MAKEOVER.
YOU HAVE TO UPDATE IT.
THIS WORKS GREAT, MAN.
LIKE WHEN I SAID THAT PUTIN
NEEDED TO BE REMOVED FROM POWER.
NO.
SOMEONE ELSE CAME OUT AND SAID,
NO, THEY GAVE AN UPDATE.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEN YOU ASKED ME ABOUT IT AND I
SAID, NO, YOU HAVE TO GO BY THE
UPDATE.
THIS UPDATE THING, I LOVE IT.
IT WORKS GREAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE I LOVE?
ICE CREAM.
>> Greg: WHO DOESN'T?
GO AHEAD AND LAUGH BUT THE
JOKE'S ON US.
WE KNEW THE LAPTOP WAS REAL BUT
WERE PUNISHED FOR SAYING IT AND
NOT THE GOOD KIND OF PUNISHMENT
THAT INVOLVES A SAFE WORD.
DON'T BUY THIS ACT OF
CONTRITION.
THE MEDIA NEVER ADMITS TO
ANYTHING UNLESS THEY'RE PLANNING
TO DO SOMETHING WORSE.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HIS TV SHOWS INSPIRED AMERICANS
TO DO MORE READING.
FOUNDER OF THE LOFTIST PARTY
DOT-COM, MICHAEL LOFTIST.
SHE'S MON CONSERVATIVE THAN A
TURTLENECK WEARING ANOTHER
TURTLENECK, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
TAMMY BRUCE.
AND HE'S MORE RIPPED THAN A
GROCERY BAG IN THE RAIN, RETIRED
U.S. MARINE CORPS, BOMB
TECHNICIAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, JOHNNIE JOEY JOE.
AND SHE'S LIKE BARBED WIRE,
SKINNY, SHARP AND A LOT OF
FELONS CAN'T SEEM TO GET OVER
HER, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT.
HOW ARE YOU DOING OVER THERE?
>> I'M HANGING IN.
FEELING GOOD.
>> Greg: BARELY, YOU HAVE NO
EXCUSE TO FEEL GOOD BUT OK.
I DON'T SEE WHY.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD GO
AGAINST THE EVIDENCE OF YOUR
PHYSICAL --
>> THOSE ARE ALLEGATIONS.
ALLEGATIONS.
>> Greg: I JUST GO BY HOW YOU
LOOK, AND YOU LOOK TERRIBLE.
NO, I'M KIDDING.
JESSIE WATERS OF ALL PEOPLE MADE
A GOOD POINT ON "THE FIVE"
SAYING THAT THE "WASHINGTON
POST" AUTHENTICATED EVERY SINGLE
E-MAIL EXCEPT THE STUFF THAT
MENTIONED JOE.
LIKE, WHAT ARE THE ODDS OF THAT?
THEY WALKED IN -- THEY
COMPLETELY WALKED AROUND THAT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE TIMING?
>> WELL, THE TIMING IS SO THEY
CAN LOOK BACK